[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be taking
another look at the trailer for the
latest installment of the fantastic
beasts films while i know many of us
were anxiously awaiting a new trailer on
the 24th of february for now we'll have
to make do with more theories built
around the one that dropped back in
december so let's get into it okay so
today's topic is going to focus on
queenie goldstein the beautiful and
charismatic youngest sister of american
aura tina goldstein and what exactly her
role will be in the secrets of
dumbledore as i'm sure most of you can
recall at the end of the last fantastic
beast film the crimes of grindelwald
queenie quite abruptly alters her
allegiances within the wizarding world
betraying her loyalty to her friends and
sister in favor of supporting the dark
wizard gelet grindelwald now i see that
queenie switches sides quite abruptly
because in my opinion it really didn't
seem like her interests were all that
aligned with grindelwald and the beliefs
of his other followers or acolytes as
they're commonly known in fact when she
first comes face to face with
grindelwald halfway through the second
film she seems extremely terrified
so how did she go from the somewhat
ditzy albeit incredibly charming queenie
that we meet in the first film to the
dare i say dangerous and empowered woman
we see presented in the secrets of
dumbledore trailer and what will this
new portrayal of queenie mean for her
character arc and overall role in the
film i think to answer these questions
we must first start the beginning of
queenie's story within the films when we
first met queenie in fantastic beasts
and where to find them she's a low-level
employee working in the one permit
office for the magical congress of the
united states of america otherwise known
as makusa and although we discover
almost immediately after being
introduced to her that queenie is an
incredibly gifted legitimate born with
the innate ability to enter another
witch or wizard's mind and interpret
their thoughts she doesn't seem all that
confident in her abilities or position
as a witch she seems insistent that tina
or tini as she affectionately refers to
her sister is the career woman out of
the two of them and that all she does is
get coffee or fix the toilets
to me this suggests that quinny doesn't
put too much emphasis on pursuing higher
achievements within a more traditional
wizarding career path say that of
becoming an aura or professor that kind
of thing
perhaps she simply wasn't interested or
maybe she thought putting her magical
abilities into a career was a waste of
time whatever the reason it's pretty
clear that queenie doesn't put all that
much thought into her magic another
example of this is the way that she
reads people apologizing to newt's
commander after looking into his mind
without his permission
i know i'm sorry i can't help it people
are easiest to read when they're hurting
she says
in this instance it's clear that she
doesn't even have to try when practicing
legitimacy rather it just comes to her
so in my opinion it's her lack of
interest in magical pursuits that make
her so open to her attraction to jacob
kowalski the american nomads she meets
alongside newt in fact not only does she
seem accepting of his presence she seems
utterly fascinated a real life no manage
in her brownstone
so when the movie ends with her visiting
jacob in his bakery it's really not all
that surprising of course the next film
picks up with the two of them wrapped up
in a magically induced engagement
courtesy of queenie to me it all seems a
bit odd but i guess the logic behind it
makes sense as the audience will have to
deduce that between the two movies jacob
and queenie became romantically involved
however not in any formal way due to the
macusa laws which at the time forbade
witches and wizards from having any form
of relationship with no matches in the
united states because of this it would
seem that jacob refused to officially
commit to queenie for fear of her being
arrested for the crime of being with him
so queenie decided to take matters into
her own hands and put an enchantment on
jacob to coerce him into marrying her
of course upon catching up with newt
he's able to see what queenie's done and
breaks the enchantment this leads to
queenie and jacob having quite a large
argument which ends with queenie
disapparating to paris in search of her
sister
unable to find tina upon her arrival in
france queenie is approached by an
acolyte and then meets grindelwald as
mentioned previously this is the
interaction in which queenie seems
incredibly frightened of grindelwald and
his followers
but i guess after hearing what he has to
say which is basically that he's
fighting for a wizarding world in which
everyone is free to love whomever they
choose which is of course total bs she
comes around to the idea that maybe this
guy isn't so bad after all
in any case i really do feel like it
happens quite abruptly of course the
film ends with her choosing to leave
jacob bettina and newt to join
grindelwald so that she can help create
a future in which she can be with jacob
honestly if that doesn't sound misguided
i don't know what does
in any case now we're left to wonder
where her allegiance with this dark
wizard will take her it seems quite
obvious why grindelwald wanted to lure
her to his side for her legitimacy
abilities after all we see her use this
valuable skill at the very end of the
crimes of grindelwald as she shares
credence barebones feelings with gelat
saying
you need to be careful he's not sure he
made the right choice be very gentle
with him
now i find the way she words this to be
quite interesting to me it suggests that
she doesn't have similar feelings when
she tells grindelwald of credence's
emotions she doesn't seem to empathize
with them at all
she simply presents them matter of
factly
it would seem that grindelwald despite
terrifying her earlier in the movie
doesn't need to be careful with queenie
she seems to feel that she's made the
right choice which brings us to the
secrets of dumbledore trailer here we
are presented with a very confident less
colorful version of the queenie we have
come to know and love
she's present in just a couple scenes
one of which looks to be a flashback
queenie and jacob were embracing in his
bakery back in new york
here her hair is the rich gold color it
used to be and she's wearing the same
pink outfit that she wore the end of the
first film when she shows up at the
bakery
the second scene though is the only
current depiction we get of queenie in
the trailer dressed all in black with
slicked back platinum blonde hair she
carries herself with a certain strength
and purpose we haven't seen from queenie
before gone is the happy-go-lucky charm
that she used to bounce around with
so what could this mean for queenie in
the secret of dumbledore
well i think it's pretty clear that
she's gotten a bit lost in her pursuit
of being free to love whomever she wants
i would wager that even though she tells
herself that her love of jacob is why
she's fighting alongside grindelwald she
barely even thinks about him anymore
instead she's motivated by the power
she's assuming
she's finally found a reason to invest
in her magical abilities for a greater
purpose
something more than just being another
macusa employee or an ilvermorny
professor
for the greater good i think that in
this upcoming film we're going to see a
whole new side of queenie a powerful
woman who thanks to her talent as a
legilimens has perhaps become one of
grindelwald's most trusted acolytes i
believe we'll see her present for many
meetings of importance in the movie so
that she can share the thoughts and
desires of those grindelwald is meeting
with
sadly i think in her misguided attempt
to secure a future in which she thinks
she'll have the freedom to love jacob
she will actually come up against jacob
and the others i think she'll believe
she's doing it for the greater good
and unfortunately i think this will mean
that more tragedy is on the way for our
protagonists newt jacob and tina i'm
hopeful that by the end of the secrets
of dumbledore queenie will recognize
that she's taken an unwise turn down a
dark path and that she'll return to her
old self once more i don't think we'll
get the overly bubbly queenie that we
first met in fantastic beasts but
perhaps that's not altogether a bad
thing
hopefully the queenie that emerges will
be a more confident witch who values her
abilities and her purpose but with some
of her old charm left intact well that's
it for today's video as always i'd love
to know what you think what do you
believe will be queenie's role in the
new movie
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
for the greater good
you